Let's talk about my boy,
Scott Pruitt.
(sighs)
Now, the left wants you to think
that he's some corrupt grifter
using his role
as head of the EPA
to milk the government
for every penny it's worth
just because he spends millions
of dollars on personal security
and takes Black Hawk
helicopter rides to coal mines.
But he's not exploiting
government perks.
Look at him on his way
to dinner last night.
(sirens wailing)
Yeah.
(laughter)
That's a great car.
Great car.
Gets negative three miles
to the gallon,
which is also the EPA's
new fuel efficiency standard.
See, Scott's not the kind of guy
who uses his office
only for personal gain.
Sometimes he does it
for his wife.
A new potential conflict
for the EPA administrator
Scott Pruitt.
He's now accused
of using a government aide
to help score his wife
a Chick-fil-A franchise.
Pruitt had
his taxpayer-funded staff
ask about a business opportunity
for his wife.
The idea, according to the Post,
was for Pruitt's wife
to operate one
of the restaurant's franchises.
Yes, getting his wife
a Chick-fil-A is adorable.
(laughter)
We all know
the ten-year anniversary is tin,
15 is crystal,
and apparently,
25 is mostly white meat
with a couple pickles.
But just like Chick-fil-A's
evangelical agenda,
this story keeps going.
The shameless media has been
hounding Scott all month.
Pruitt ordered thousands
of personalized office supplies.
That includes
12 silver personalized pens
with the EPA's seal
and Pruitt's signature on them
for the low, low cost
of more than $1,500.
Now, that breaks down
to $130 per pen,
believe it or not.
Oh, okay. Okay.
$130 may sound like a lot,
but these pens write
in crude oil.
(laughter)
Quill, baby, quill.
And then there was this.
Pruitt used his staff,
his official staff,
to run personal errands
on the taxpayers' dime,
such as finding him
an apartment to rent
or personally tour
the properties,
even to call
a Trump International Hotel
in Washington
to see if he could buy
a used mattress.
-Ah.
-(laughter)
Ah, yes.
The very best adjective
to precede a mattress:
"used."
(laughter)
Followed closely by,
"You know, your mom and I
actually created you on this."
(audience groaning)
Now, don't believe the hype.
Don't believe it.
He's a good man,
not some con artist.
If he were really
abusing his position,
he would at least try
to hide it.
This, this is as exposed
as that secretary
who showed ankle to Mike Pence.
You see, there's something else
going on here
if you look close enough.
Chick-fil-A?
That's basic sustenance.
Mattresses?
Just a place to sleep.
Pens? Tools to write new laws.
Scott Pruitt isn't swindling
American taxpayers.
No, he's creating
a second Earth.
(laughter)
Now, sure, he's not done.
He'll probably add
a form of currency
and a taxpayer-funded
Moon Porsche,
but Pruitt is making Earth 2,
which is good because,
let's face it,
our planet is getting toasty
for some reason.
Someone should look into that.